and speaking of bullies how about we go
over to lauren bobert right now
lauren bobert this week sent a letter to
transportation secretary pete buttige
begging him for 33 million dollars to
construct a new bridge in her district a
new bridge that she says
is going to help with evacuations it's
going to help with emergency vehicles
because you know colorado
has a lot of wildfires
and bobert says look we got you got this
money from the infrastructure bill we
would love for you to you know come and
spend this 33 million dollars on a new
bridge people need it people could die
without it honestly all good points
right
but the irony here of course
is that lauren bobert
has spent the last year
mocking
pete buddha judge's sexuality
you know when he took paternity leave
she went on
national media and said he's probably
learning how to chest feed
you've mocked his husband
you've mocked everything about this man
you have blamed him for things that are
not even his fault
and now you have the audacity
to look up to him and say hey
how about 33 million over here for a new
bridge from my district so i don't you
know
get creamed in my election i kind of
need to do something for these people
because i've done nothing
so would you help me out
now
i will say
she should not be punished
just because she is a horrible person
now
rephrase that her constituents should
not be punished just because they sent a
horrible person to congress
they have the opportunity to write that
wrong actually i think it's coming up
next week right they got that primary
don coram the republican running against
her you've got democrats
that have switched from being democrats
to registered either independents or
republicans so they can go vote against
lauren bobert in that primary like there
is this massive concerted effort to get
this individual out of office
and it's because she's a horrible person
and for the republicans
in her district
it's because she's completely
ineffective
that's why she's sending this last
minute pitch to bootage
you know that's why she's pretending
that she hasn't spent the last year
basically calling him a horrible person
because he's not a straight white man
she needs that 33 million dollar bridge
to be able to show her constituents yes
i may do crazy things sometimes but hey
look i delivered for you
and unfortunately they do need the
bridge
and i personally do not believe
in abusing political power
you know just to make an individual pay
you know just to punish a political
rival that's not okay
you know just ask chris christie and
bridgegate
something everybody forgot about a
scandal that honestly today probably
wouldn't even be a scandal
considering the scandals we see these
days
but again
it's the same thing with marjorie taylor
green you can't spend your whole life
just being a horrible person to
everybody you come in contact with
and then expect them to be nice to you
right this is basic you know
growing up type stuff your mothers your
fathers anybody any kind of you know
adult figure in your life should have
taught you this when you were young
children
you get back what you put in i know my
mother told me that a million times
she'll still tell me that to this day
and that's not saying that you have to
sit there and suffer the slings and
arrows of everyone coming after you
you can stand up for yourself absolutely
but there's a difference between
standing up for yourself and being an
outright bully which is what people like
lauren bobert and marjorie taylor green
have become